Stephen dang thank you for coming today
I am from Capital One located in our
locations in Dallas I work in the auto
finance sector and we have a slew of
tools that are architected for different
levels of resiliency which and I've
worked on a large number of them so I've
seen everything from internal tools that
can be down for a week with no issues
maybe a mad email or two and I've seen
and I've worked on projects that have
that required to be up all the time like
our Loan Servicing where we need to take
customer data and take payments all day
every day 24 hours a day so hopefully
you're here for architecting for active
active resiliency and I'm gonna straight
off the bat say act I say I say active
active very lightly as you'll see active
active is extremely complex and there
are many tiers of different resilience
ease and sometimes it's not always worth
it to be completely active active so
what is resiliency right off the bat
resiliency I like we like to break down
into two different levels we have the
data level and we have the service level
at the service level you can look at
resiliency as availability where it's
kind of the percentage of time your
service is doing what it's supposed to
do and you can look at durability as how
how durable your dead your data is and
whenever something goes down what is
your systems resilience - um - losing
data or your resistance - losing data
now your system or you dip your system
can be available but not durable that's
when your system accepts rites but
doesn't necessarily commit the
transactions and it can also be of
durable and available wear if your
system can't make enough replicas of
your data then we're not going to accept
rites today we're gonna kind of consider
the trade-offs between between raising
the availability and durability as well
as associated complexities with that so
I don't know if everybody seen this but
um this is waffles the dog one of my
favorite dogs on that shows up whenever
am
zhan has a 404 I do think waffles is one
of the cutest dogs on there so I'm not
picked I'm picking on Amazon
specifically for two reasons first
reason is because I think Amazon has the
cutest 404 page and the second reason is
because no matter how big or how small
your company you can have outages and
you're gonna have failures and even a
company if you've heard of this small
service called AWS which Amazon hosts
and provides even they can have outages
so it's important to have a plan so
first off we're gonna talk about some of
the basics then we're gonna talk about
considerations and trade-offs we're
going to talk about common patterns to
increase your resiliency and we're also
going to talk about a couple tools and
services that will help you and that'll
be dispersed throughout the presentation
so first off is our ingredients and I
say ingredients because I really really
like food so if you guys have dinner
plans tonight that has delicious food
let me know so we're gonna talk about
first availability what is availability
in simple terms your availability can be
calculated by your normal operation time
divided by your total time and slightly
more technical terms we your
availability time is your mean time
before feeling and your total time is
your meantime before failures plus the
time it takes to recover from those
failures
now that's availability of your one
system but what happens when we have
multiple systems obviously not
everything is going to be monolithic
these days we're venturing towards a
very distributed world so let's say we
have component X and we have component Y
and component Y is a downstream
dependency of component X if component X
has two nines of availability that
equates to about three days and 15 hours
give or take a leap year if we if
component Y has four nines of
availability we're gonna have about 52
minutes of downtime per year when you
put them in series where X is dependent
on Y your availability can be calculated
via the product of those availabilities
and we're down
to ninety eight point nine nine
availability and our downtime per year
is now three days 16 hours and 33
minutes and if you've noticed our new
availability levels are lower than the
other components individually so what do
we take away from this more downstream
dependencies less availability but what
happens when we have something in
parallel versus in series say we have
two x's or 1x and your availability is
99% again that's three days and 15 hours
per year when you put two x's in
parallel you can your availability your
availability becomes four nines of
availability that's only 52 minutes per
year when you put three x's in parallel
you're down to a whopping 31 seconds and
that is HUGE by putting 3 the pit by
putting 3 of your components in parallel
you're tremendously at adding or
reducing your available sorry increasing
your availability and reducing the
amount of time that you're down if you
want to do a little more reading into
this um there's a highly published
article called Oracle's maximum
availability architecture and it's there
it's often referenced but what do we
take away from this is that the more
replication that we have the more
replicas they're more availability we
have and but I will say this costs
multiply quickly every time we add a new
component we're multiplying our
infrastructure costs immediately so
let's stop let's start off with the
basics what is basic active architecture
well basically factor FACA texture is
kind of like what my appointment is I
have a tiny little apartment I have my
fiance and I have my cat and if we have
dirty dishes on our stovetop we can't
cook if we want to cook we've got to get
rid of those dirty dishes go clean them
up and then we can finally make
something on the stove and that's kind
of what basic active architecture is we
have our web layer or application layer
or service layer and we have our data
layer whether that's a datastore
document store or a database now this is
good for some applications but it very
often is not nearly
enough but what it is good at is being
cheap being simple and being fast to
market sometimes you need sometimes you
need these things for maybe a POC or MVP
and that's what you're going for right
off the bat but if this is in production
and something fails you're gonna have
lots of manual intervention whenever you
fail over you have a very low level of
resiliency because you have downstream
dependencies but nothing increasing your
availability and later down the line if
you're looking to scale this looking to
add more customers hoping to always be
on you're gonna need a lot of rework
some examples of this would be internal
tools that if they went down could
possibly be inconvenient but it's often
not enough so what's next
active passive architecture and to use
another cooking example I don't know how
many grandmas are like mine but my
grandma has two freezers completely
separate ones outside ones inside and
when I asked her why she said that
whenever one breaks she has another one
and I said okay so basic active passive
architecture kind of looks something
like this
we have our set of applications or
components in one region region a we
have our main database or our master
database in region a and we have a read
replica as well as one web or and one
app in a second failover region
whenever something fails we move
everything to our region B when we
wanted to begin bringing everything back
over to our original region we
instantiate another read replica fail
everything back over and we bring up a
new read replica now these passive
components that you see that are light
colored you can have there are often two
versions of it you can have either have
a hot or a cold standby wet hot standbys
you have instances with code but they're
not taking any traffic and when you have
a cold standby you have automated
failover scripts that you have planned
for this at this level we have
statelessness that comes into play
whenever you do failover to that other
region it's absolutely critical
there anything running in your second
region is going to produce the exact
same results as if you were running it
in your original region so what is it
good for we are heavily decreasing
downtime downstream dependency or sorry
decreasing down times and we also have a
set of backup services so this is at
this level where we have backups for our
data and we also have backups for our
services so we increasing availability
and increasing durability it's often a
very good balance for most applications
but at this level we begin increasing
cost and complexity and we also have
that potential for data loss
whenever you failover from one region to
the next your recovery time is going to
look at whatever your the amount of time
that it takes to start up your new set
of servers but for most applications
this is where you're gonna want to fall
because it's a good balance between
costs and complexity and availability
and durability this is good for low
revenue customer facing applications
some ecommerce apps and in batch
processes that can possibly make up for
any lag that you may have associated it
that aren't mission-critical for
real-time and possibly still meet your
SLA s-so active-active this is where
your complexity and your costs become
extremely high o in active/active we
have multiple instances of our servers
taking traffic at the same time this may
either be to balance out your load or
maybe you have geological constraints
that you need to maybe you're setting up
in China as well as the US as well as
the UK and you may need to appropriate
for that latency and depending on your
data consistency you may not you may
need region local data stores or you may
need you may need one source of truth
your database and data store
implementation are going to depend
extremely heavily on what technologies
you use if your public facing your DNS
we need to know about your public IPS as
well as both sets of servers and if your
internal facing your application logic
would need to know about both servers so
what is great about active active
obviously it's always on
at least hopefully right we're gonna
minimize our data loss and we're gonna
hopefully have zero intervention
whenever something fails this is where
everything becomes much more expensive
much more complex and we're gonna have
some limited tooling when we get to
active active data stores our active
active services we are we begin to limit
ourselves in terms of what types of
technologies we can use in order to
write all of our transactions to now
this is a group active active would be
used often in emergency services life
threatening services things like airline
comptroller's or if you have a mission
critical application like Google's
search engine or at Capital One we have
our investing and loan payments and
streams this is where active active
would come into play where you need to
take payments all day every day so our
considerations and trade-offs our
appetizers if you will we're going to
talk a little bit about first off data
replication data replication we need to
begin thinking about how durable our
data is so let's take this simple
application we have a request that goes
into our app or service and that app
does some type of transaction off of our
master database and we have a read
replica that's replicating off of our
master database we begin adding a lot of
complexity just based off of including
that read replica into our pipeline this
is very typical with this read read
replica and master setup and what we
need to begin considering or very early
off is what type of data are we
replicating and how or how are we
replicated it and how often were
replicating it maybe you had
transactions or user data that you need
to replicate synchronously or maybe you
have some maybe if you're serving up
videos or media content that can be
asynchronously replicated later down the
line and that's perfectly fine for you
whenever we do in add in or read
replicas we need to consider the
replication lag as well as the latency
that's added for per request and
transaction whenever we write to our
database and we need to also consider
whatever database we're using what type
of retry policy
that they have and is that going to
increase the amount of latency per right
so let's kick it off with this we have
active active data store now at face
value this looks really really good
and I think most people were agree avoid
this
now when we have when we have active
active data stores we have obviously to
master databases in sync with each other
every time you write to one of the other
databases you're you're writing you're
also replicating that data over to the
other but then we add the issue of what
happens when you have collisions what
which database is the source of truth
which database is auditable and this is
this is where we need to begin treading
very carefully latency also becomes a
very large issue here we need to have
sync if you need synchronous replication
then we're going to increase in our
Lancie and have higher potential for
collisions so right off the bat we need
to consider kanri 8 can we a
synchronously replicate our data and do
we really need an active active data
store not always now in this scenario we
have both of our apps in each region
writing to one single master data store
and if your DV fails your master
database fails you can promote your read
replicas and have all your applications
writing to your new master and this is
very critical because we are still
active active at the service level we're
just an active active at the data level
so if you need higher availability but
you don't need strong data consistency
or you don't need high data durability
often this is good enough for you and
that's an important distinction whenever
possible we should be using services and
resources within the region but and
that's a trade-off between your
availability and durability that needs
to be made very early on so some tools
and services that I want to share with
you guys that I found interesting a GC
Peas cloud spanner Mike Asher is cosmos
and AWS is Aurora all offer some type of
read/write replicas or a multi master
global configuration that can help you
with those needs but you do need to
consider the collisions
up front I will say that what with cloud
spanner May uses a nonce the standard
sequel driver so you if you need to
re-architect it would require
non-trivial work
what cosmos DB it's actually pretty
interesting is they support multiple
data data types so you can have key
value as well as a graph database with
our table within your scene database
with Aurora as they've often they have a
new offering called Aurora serverless
which you only pay for underlying cost
whenever you're not writing transactions
which would heavily help you with those
costs occurred incurred whenever you
increase your complexity in
infrastructure levels if you don't want
to go the manage rail and don't want to
be tied to a cloud provider there is
Apache Cassandra and my sequel and the
reason why I want to point these guys
now is because
Cassandra is heavily used at Capital One
and Netflix has also stated use of
Cassandra for cross region master master
data stores and my sequel is used for
github global data store as well as for
variety of uses on from Capital One so
what happens when we do failover so we
have in this scenario an API that takes
in traffic and it makes a request to an
app and it sends a message to a topic
Kafka if you well you have we have
multiple streams reading from that topic
and those streams are doing something to
a database maybe they're updating maybe
they're writing maybe they're deleting
what happens when one of your databases
fails are we gonna move or in one of our
databases over to a new region or
failing over are we going to move over
our entire pipeline maybe just the
stream and its associated database maybe
all of our streams and all the databases
so it's important to consider what we're
failing over and that's the idea of
tenancy the idea of tenancy or multi
tendency is a single unit of movement
that you need to failover in order to
have your working
pipeline once again in general we want
to contain the blast zone as much as
humanly possible failure or failure in
one region should not affect another
region and we should have a heavy amount
of regional independence whenever we're
serving up requests either at the
service level or at the data level as
well and very early on we need to begin
considering what our possible scenarios
for failover and what can we automate
right off the bat when we begin looking
at what can failover and how do we
recover from that we need to begin
looking at what we're monitoring
monitoring in terms of what's healthy
what's not healthy what we're going to
fail over and we need to ensure that the
alarms are in place for whenever things
do fail Logue analytics like kibana or
Splunk are extremely useful here but as
we increase availability and we increase
durability you're going to increase your
complexity and you're going to increase
your cost and all this is important
because not every team has the bandwidth
or the Associated cost that they want to
provide whenever you increase your
resiliency everybody wants to be active
active from the start but not everybody
needs to be active active from the start
there's lots of upfront costs and that
can possibly provide lots of value later
down the line but that's a trade-off
that needs to be considered very early
on
you also need more agents here including
software engineers sre product
management and they all need to be in
line with whatever levels are complexity
for your data and your services you can
provide so let's talk about patterns to
increase your availability first off I
do want to point out that this there are
hundreds if not thousands of different
patterns to increase the availability
and resiliency these are a couple that I
found particularly notable in the
industry and I want to share so we have
component X which calls component Y what
happens when component Y fails we can
implement a simple retry policy
keep hitting component Y until it gets
healthy but that adds a lot of
unnecessary latency and could possibly
result in timeout so the circuit breaker
pattern is when we wrap a protected
function call around a circuit breaker
object and whenever we reach a certain
threshold of failure we just stop
calling it and in Java I want to call up
Netflix's hystrix library which is an
amazing tool but retries aren't
necessarily bad they just need to be
done with lots of consideration so
that's where the X something like the
exponential backup pattern comes into
play
and in a very naive manner we every time
we have a failing call we we increase
the amount of time before our next retry
call and something like that looks like
after our first failure we wait about
200 milliseconds after our fourth
failure we wait 1,600 milliseconds and
after our ninth failure we're waiting
around 51 seconds and this allows us to
continue retrying but it allows the
failing system to recover and it gives
it more time to recover and become
healthy but in the meantime while our
dependencies are down you're probably
asking well what do we do then we have a
fallback pattern do you guys remember
waffles I hope you do he's really cute
fallback pattern is when we return a
stubbed response that maybe in turn by
way of having cute images on your 404
page or that might be a way of returning
data stored in a cache and in terms of
cache nothing comes close to memcached
and Redis there are many managed caches
out there that can help heavily help you
out AWS has elastic cache GCP has cloud
memory store and azure has its Redis
cache and the great thing about these
managed services is that you don't have
to maintain or patch your infrastructure
now for the next pattern I do want to
call out one company which is pretty
inspiring Netflix in a very naive manner
we have a web stream and
and if you don't know what Netflix is
they streaming videos for us so that we
can watch unhealthily now in 2012 or
2013
there he'll be plain that they were
using failed and it was completely
outside their control and what that
means is everybody on the east coast of
the Americas could not watch buddy the
elf or a Christmas story or whatever
you're into on Christmas Eve and that's
completely tragic because I do love
watching buddy the elf on Christmas Eve
so what they did in in a very simple
representation was they looked at what
happened when that region failed and how
we can prevent that one region how we
can prevent failures whenever that one
region does fail so they said hmm why
don't we have a set of instances running
multiple instances running within our
region and we separate it via
availability zones so whenever one
availability zone goes out we can still
serve up traffic from our available our
other
availability zones that are still
healthy and that's awesome because most
people automatically jump to cross
region active active right off the bat
whenever you say oh we need active
active let's do cross region let's do
east/west and Australia doesn't
necessarily need to be the case they're
active active within their region
they're keeping network latency to a
minimum and they're keeping their
service it's calling within the same
region and that's awesome
so we they're also increasing their our
overall availability via a horizontal
scaling by adding multiple copies of
those instances within the same region
another one I want to call out is a
synchronicity and over the years the
past couple years asynchronous and event
based notifications and driven events
have become extremely popular by ways of
rabbitmq or Kafka and right up and a lot
of people who some people think that oh
we're using this to maybe just have
batch processes but it all
so immediately adds to your resiliency
levels why because we're decoupling
components in this scenario we have our
app which writes to a topic and it gets
to fire and forget that message once
it's done the app doesn't need to know
anything else it lets the message sit
inside of its topic until any worker
cues or any workers need to pull that
message off messages can sit in the
queue until they're ready to be
processed and asynchronicity
alleviates a lot of that unnecessary
waiting on the applications or the
producers part we're also reducing any
or reducing the chance of cascading
failures and timeouts and we're also
reducing the network congestion
associated with the app waiting on
worker queues to do its job
unfortunately using work accused streams
and asynchronous the asynchronous design
isn't always the most straightforward
and that needs to be looked at very
carefully and if the original producer
does need to look at the results somehow
you do need to keep track of some type
of job ID this also adds directly to
infrastructure costs and complexity but
it is overall a very powerful tool to
minimum to minimize the effects of
failure on your system so in terms of
tools that we can use Kafka is very
widely used and a lot of spaces
developed at LinkedIn and it's now open
source one of the big things
Kafka sells as an open source tool is
its extremely high availability and
throughput
it also offers multi node and multi
cluster configurations and your messages
can sit in your queues and if you need
to you can reread your messages whenever
you need to as you can D do plater Kafka
follows a smart consumer and dumb broker
model which is the exact opposite of
what rabbit MQ has to offer they follow
a smart broker and dumb consumer model
which means that you can develop very
large complex topological schemes for
routing your messages rabbitmq does
support multiple types of protocols if
you if that's something you need and
then they have very well-defined
consistency rules
oh and another thing I do want to
mention that not every shop has the
capacity to manage a Costco or rabbit MQ
cluster in way of managed services you
have Google pub/sub SQS Kinesis and
things like that if you want a managed
service but you don't always have to
take one of these patterns and deploy it
you can combine patterns it's combining
asynchronicity queues and workers worker
streams and maybe the exponential
back-off method it become extremely
powerful whenever you need to increase
your resiliency heavily to more tools
and services I do want to mention our
chaos monkey if you're unfamiliar with
chaos monkey it is developed at Netflix
they rent it's used to randomly
terminate instances inside of your
environment and at first that sounds
really really scary and it also sounds
like oh do all I have to deal with
failure once a day uh-huh in general
it's used to schedule your downtime so
that you can practice what happens
during a real failover
Netflix famously runs this in their
production environment on a daily basis
so take that with what you will and the
last thing I want to talk about talk
about before we go is server list server
list is a very very hot topic right now
and there's a it's a its it brought up
in a conversation a lot if you if you're
unsure what it is it is essentially a
function as a service you're putting in
a small bit of code and you're waiting
on events to happen on services inside
of your cloud provider to kick off this
function all of the following have
issues with debugging monitoring and
deployment as well as version management
but the one thing that it does provide
that reduces the is reducing cost
dramatically in general functions don't
run whenever you're not utilizing it and
they do go they do go down and go dark
and it does encourage stateless
programming going back to before
whenever we want to deploy to multiple
regions or multiple availability zones
we want to make sure that we get the
same output no matter which region we're
running in so as
with every talk we've only hit we're
only touching on the tip of the iceberg
we talked about like planning early and
statelessness and phthalo and having a
plan whenever you failover
but this is just the very beginning
resiliency is a very deep topic that
requires lots and lots of time and
effort and everybody's solution is gonna
be different because everybody's
business requirement is gonna be
different and that's where the fun
begins it's when you begin architecting
for your project my name is Steven dang
thank you
[Applause]